Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Beh, dopo questa presentazione
avevo due possibilità:
entrare o non entrare.
In ogni caso, ero in uno
dei futuri possibili.
La fisica dell'ultimo secolo
ha mostrato un'antica intuizione
del misticismo orientale:
ossia che il mondo,
lo spazio in cui viviamo,
è un complicato tessuto,
una rete dinamica, pulsante, di eventi.
Citando le parole di Carlo Rovelli,
non solo le cose
possono entrare in relazione
ma sono proprio le relazioni
che determinano la nozione di cosa.
Io sono un ricercatore
dell'Università di Udine
e mi occupo di reti, guarda caso.
Le reti sono un modello
estremamente semplice, lineare, appagante;
ma anche onnipresente.
Internet; il web; le reti sociali;
il nostro cervello.
Ciò che mi affascina,
di questo modello delle reti,
è che contengono,
includono al loro interno
tre modelli interessanti,
che cercherò di illustrarvi
in questa presentazione:
il modello lineare, il modello ramificato,
il modello circolare.
Sono tutti rappresentati in questa rete,
o grafo, come lo chiamano i matematici.
Partiamo dal modello lineare:
che cos'è il modello lineare?
Il modello lineare
è una successione incessante,
senza possibilità di alternative,
di istanti.
Corrisponde al concetto di fatalismo,
e può essere visualizzata
mediante un cammino,
quindi una successione di punti.
Vi spiegherò questo modello
usando l'idea, il fenomeno
dei "sei gradi di separazione".
Qualcuno conosce la teoria
del piccolo mondo?
Be', forse i miei studenti sì,
visto che l'ho insegnata, quest'anno,
e ce ne sono qui presenti.
La teoria del piccolo mondo
ci dice questo:
prendete una persona a caso,
sul pianeta Terra.
Un meccanico di Tijuana, in Messico;
o un fruttivendolo di Perth, in Australia.
Quanti gradi di separazione
ci separano da queste persone?
Se conoscessi direttamente il meccanico,
ci sarebbe un grado di separazione;
e se lo conoscessi indirettamente,
tramite un'altra persona,
magari un mio amico che studia in Messico,
ci sarebbero due gradi
di separazione; e così via.
Il fenomeno del piccolo mondo ci dice
che nonostante il mondo sia grande,
la rete sia vastissima
in termini di numero di nodi, di attori,
le distanze tra persone,
tra attori sono molto piccole.
In matematica diciamo che sono
logaritmiche, il numero di nodi:
quindi molto piccolo.
Agli inizi del secolo scorso, nel 1929,
uno scrittore semisconosciuto,
Frigyes Karinthy,
scrive un racconto intitolato
"Chains - catene"
da cui ho estratto questo paragrafo.
Lui immagina di scegliere
a caso una persona
tra il miliardo e mezzo
che vivevano allora sulla Terra,
e scommette che con non più
di cinque individui intermedi,
cioè non più di sei passaggi,
lui riesce a raggiungere,
mediante la rete di conoscenze,
questa persona.
È il primo a intuire questo fenomeno:
però lo intuisce a livello letterario,
nel senso che la sua
è un'intuizione di pura fantasia.
Per me è sorprendente
che 40 anni dopo, nel 1967,
uno psicologo americano
molto famoso, Stanley Milgram,
conduce il suo famoso esperimento
sul piccolo mondo
e in un certo senso conferma
l'intuizione di Karinthy.
Cosa fa Milgram?
Prende l'elenco telefonico -
non c'era Internet, allora;
sceglie a caso un centinaio di persone
e chiede a queste persone di inviare
una lettera, un pacchetto, un plico
a un destinatario che vive
a 1000 chilometri di distanza.
Lo devono inviare, però,
attraverso la rete
di conoscenze personali.
Alla fine si reca dal suo amico,
raccoglie le lettere arrivate -
naturalmente alcune
si sono perse per strada.
Sulle lettere sono stati annotati
tutti i passaggi di queste catene,
di questi cammini.
Calcola la media delle lunghezze
di questi cammini,
ed esce il numero sei, cioè in realtà 5,9.
Da qui il mito dei
"sei gradi di separazione".
Questa ipotesi,
questa idea del piccolo mondo,
quindi del fatto che il mondo,
nonostante sia molto grande,
è connesso da distanze
molto piccole tra gli individui,
è poi stata ripetuta,
è stata confermata recentemente
in un esperimento -
un lavoro fatto peraltro in collaborazione
con il Politecnico di Milano -
sulla rete Facebook.
Usando un campione molto più grande
di quello usato da Milgram,
un campione di un miliardo
e mezzo di persone -
i numeri che ritornano:
lo stesso numero di persone
che Karenthy immaginava
sul pianeta Terra 80 anni prima.
I gradi di separazione sono diminuiti:
sono oggi 4,5.
Il secondo modello di cui vorrei parlarvi
è un modello ramificato.
Implementa, realizza
il concetto di libero arbitrio;
e può essere rappresentato
mediante un "albero"
di punti di scelta
e cammini futuri possibili.
Un giardino di sentieri
che si biforcano, potremmo dire.
Il ragionamento temporale -
e qui parliamo di tempo -
ha origini molto antiche,
e risale proprio ai filosofi greci.
Aristotele è il primo
a interrogarsi su questioni temporali,
con il problema dei "futuri contingenti".
Cosa sono i futuri contingenti?
Sono proposizioni
che si riferiscono a eventi futuri.
Aristotele si chiede,
prendiamo questa proposizione:
"Ci sarà domani una battaglia navale?"
Oppure, riformulata ai tempi odierni:
ci sarà un terremoto domani,
o domani sorgerà il sole?
Aristotele si chiede:
possiamo noi definire un valore di verità
in una logica binaria, vero o falso,
per queste affermazioni, oggi?
Possiamo dire che oggi
queste affermazioni sono vere o false?
Nella sua semplice saggezza,
mia madre direbbe
che solo il Signore sa la risposta.
E alcuni secoli dopo, Guglielmo di Ockham
non disse cose molto diverse,
con tutto il rispetto.
La risposta, disse,
non sta nella mente dell'uomo
ma sta solo nella mente di Dio.
In realtà, Ockham attribuisce all'uomo
una proprietà molto importante,
la proprietà del libero arbitrio.
Quindi la proprietà
di scegliere tra diversi -
fare delle scelte, e quindi creare
diverse possibilità, diversi sentieri,
diversi futuri possibili.
E questo, in un certo senso,
spiega, dà una soluzione
al problema di Aristotele
dei futuri contingenti;
ossia, queste affermazioni
non sono inconsistenti
in quanto, se immaginiamo
una struttura ad albero,
in cui ci sono più futuri possibili -
come scherzavamo all'inizio:
in un futuro io mi sono presentato,
e vi sto dando questo talk;
in un altro sono dietro,
a bere il mio tè rilassante -
allora è perfettamente lecito
che in alcuni di questi futuri
ci sia un terremoto,
o una battaglia navale,
e in altri non ci sia;
oppure in tutti questi futuri
sorgerà il Sole domani, o la Terra finirà.
È curioso come -
Negli anni Cinquanta, un filosofo e logico
neozelandese, Arthur Prayer,
studia questi questi ragionamenti,
soprattutto quelli di Occam,
e definisce il concetto
di "logica temporale",
di cui vedete i quattro
operatori principali
della cosiddetta Branching Time Logic,
la logica temporale ramificata,
e la loro interpretazione
sulle strutture ad albero.
Non andrò oltre,
però è interessante per me farvi capire
che da queste disquisizioni filosofiche -
che possono sembrare
superficiali, per certi versi -
è nata una logica
che oggi ha importantissime applicazioni
in intelligenza artificiale,
per esempio per rappresentare
la conoscenza temporale;
e in informatica,
per analizzare il comportamento
dei sistemi reattivi, non deterministici.
Ma il terzo modello
di cui vorrei raccontarvi,
forse quello un po'
più interessante, più sorprendente,
è il modello autoreferenziale o circolare.
È un cammino che ritorna sui suoi passi:
un ciclo, diciamo in teoria dei grafi.
Un uroboro appunto,
un serpente che si mangia la coda.
L'autoreferenzialità -
o ricorsione, in matematica -
è un concetto sorprendentemente
presente in natura,
e assume la forma del frattale.
Qui vedete il broccolo romano,
che oltre a essere buonissimo
è anche un perfetto esempio di frattale.
Che cosa è un frattale?
Un frattale è una figura geometrica
che si ripete a scale diverse.
Sulla vostra destra
avete un'immagine del broccolo
nella sua interezza.
Alla vostra sinistra avete un particolare:
vedete che il particolare
assomiglia al tutto,
quindi c'è questa forma che ritorna,
questa sorta di autoreferenzialità,
di circolarità.
Questa è l'autoreferenzialità in natura.
Questa è l'autoreferenzialità
in matematica:
è sempre rischioso mostrare
delle equazioni matematiche,
in un TEDTalk.
In realtà,
a questa equazione tengo moltissimo:
innanzitutto perché è
un'equazione bellissima,
e sfido chiunque a dire il contrario,
che questa non sia poesia.
E poi è un'equazione utile.
Voi la utilizzate
tutti i giorni questa equazione,
perché è l'equazione che sta alla base
di un algoritmo che si chiama Page Rank.
E il Page Rank è l'algoritmo
che utilizza Google Search,
il motore di ricerca,
per ordinare le pagine
a fronte di una vostra interrogazione,
a fronte di una vostra richiesta.
Volendo parafrasare il significato,
interpretare, dare un'interpretazione
a questi simboli matematici,
potremmo dire che potremmo
leggerla in questo modo:
l'equazione dice
che un attore nella rete è importante
se circondato da altri attori importanti.
Avete colto la circolarità della cosa?
Sto definendo qualcosa
in termini di sé stesso.
Una autoreferenzialità -
quasi una tautologia, diremmo in logica -
anche se in realtà esiste
una soluzione ben precisa.
Sintatticamente,
dove si vede la ricorsione?
Be', Lambda è un numero.
Ha una matrice, è una struttura algebrica
che serve per codificare,
per rappresentare la rete;
x è un vettore,
quindi non potete semplificare la X
come qualcuno diceva ieri.
Sono strutture
molto differenti tra di loro.
La ricorsività, l'autoreferenzialità
sta nel fatto che la X compare
a sinistra e a destra del segno di uguale.
Quindi sto cercando di definire qualcosa
in termini di sé stesso.
Pura magia, dal mio punto di vista.
Uno dei lavori che mi ha dato
più soddisfazione
è stato quello di studiare
la storia di questa equazione.
Studiare la storia di un'equazione:
a chi era mai venuto in mente?
E pare che i primi a usarla
siano stati i sociologi negli anni '50,
affermando che una persona è prestigiosa
se riceve approvazioni
da altre persone di prestigio.
Nel 1970, è scoperta
anche in bibliometria:
una rivista è influente
se viene citata
da altre riviste influenti.
Negli anni '90 fa capolino
anche nello sport:
una squadra è forte se batte
altre squadre altrettanto forti.
Infine, negli anni 2000,
due studenti di dottorato
dell'università americana di Stanford,
Sergey Brin e Larry Page,
riscoprono per l'ennesima volta
questo mantra ricorsivo
e ne fanno il cuore pulsante
del motore di ricerca Google Search,
che diventerà sicuramente molto popolare.
Non era l'unica equazione:
ce n'è un'altra, ma è anche l'ultima.
All'Università di Udine
abbiamo studiato una variante,
assieme al collega Enrico Bozzo,
una variante di questa equazione.
Va a connotare il concetto di potere:
non di centralità, non di importanza.
Potrebbe essere,
parafrasata in questo modo:
un attore è importante
se è circondato da attori poco importanti.
Anche questa è una equazione ricorsiva:
come vedete, la X compare
a destra e a sinistra del segno di uguale.
L'abbiamo applicata in un
contesto economico di negoziazione:
se devo negoziare con qualcuno,
il mio potere di negoziazione è alto
se i miei contraenti sono poco potenti.
Se invece i miei contraenti
sono molto potenti,
se i miei contraenti
si chiamano Google, Apple, Microsoft,
chiaramente il mio potere
di negoziazione è molto piccolo.
Nel nostro caso, l'abbiamo applicata
alla rete di distribuzione
del gas naturale in Europa,
che qui vedete schematizzata
in un grafo indiretto.
La dimensione del nodo
è proporzionale al potere del nodo,
quindi vedete che i nodi grandi
sono vicini ai nodi piccoli
e viceversa:
questo è il concetto di potere.
Riavvolgendo - e qui si spiega
anche la mia maglietta -
riavvolgendo il nostro uroboro,
il nostro cammino,
potremmo tornare all'inizio.
E siamo partiti dicendo che lo spazio -
l'abbiamo sentito anche stamattina -
è una trama:
la trama della realtà, diceva la Vidotto.
Lo spazio è una rete, una rete di eventi.
Perché non proporre quindi,
in questo finale,
un'idea un po' originale?
Il tempo come una rete: la rete del tempo.
In fondo, il modello della rete
contiene la linearità, la ramificazione
e addirittura la circolarità.
Che hanno sicuramente, come abbiamo visto,
a che fare col tempo.
Purtroppo, il margine temporale
che mi separa dalla fine
di questo intervento
è troppo breve per investigare oltre
questa brillante intuizione.
Magari potremmo chiedere
a qualche fisico teorico
se questa intuizione ha senso.
Non mi resta altro che lasciarvi
con una delle più belle citazioni
che mi siano mai state
suggerite sul tempo.
E augurare a tutti la bellezza
qui, in questo mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)